also genau wir stehen hier gerade vor
dem neuen lager rein kommt man bisher
noch nicht also presse wird tatsächlich
nur bis hier hin gelassen und dann sagt
die polizei auch bis hierhin und nicht
weiter also rein konnten wir in das
lager noch nicht wir haben aber immer
wieder mit flüchtlingen und menschen die
eben hierhin ziehen mussten oder müssen
geredet und den krauts tatsächlich davor
in dieses lager ein ziehen zu müssen
denn man hat gehört oder es wurden eben
auch fotos geschickt davon dass die
zustände wohl fast ja am rande des
erträglichen sein
man sieht auch hier das immer wieder
autos und lkws rein und rausfahren weil
dieses lager einfach noch lange nicht
fertig ist also es heißt es gibt kaum
elektrizität kein fliessendes wasser die
sanitären anlagen sind wohl auch eine
katastrophe von daher ja viele
flüchtlinge möchten hier nicht unbedingt
rein und bleiben lieber auf der straße
weil die zuständig ebenso untragbar sind
jetzt wird von offizieller seite gesagt
doch die flüchtlinge ziehen ein ins neue
lager da gibt es unterschiedliche zahlen
die dort kursieren
welche beobachtungen machst du denn sind
mittlerweile mehr flüchtlinge ins neue
lager eingezogen oder sind sie weiterhin
auf der straße und die die auf der
straße leben jetzt schon über eine woche
wie versorgen die sich hilft da die
bevölkerung helfen der organisation wie
funktioniert das
also wenn wir einmal hier hinter mich
schauen
da hinten in der straße da waren heute
morgen um 7 uhr standen wir schon hier
also sechs uhr deutsche zeit standen ich
glaube bis zu 1000 flüchtlinge die eben
von der polizei von der straße eben raus
gekarrt wurden weil die griechische
regierung und eben die polizei die
flüchtlinge ich auf der straße überhaupt
nicht haben möchte
also es sind definitiv heute wieder mehr
menschen ins lager gezogen man sieht ja
auch hier immer noch so eine kleine
schlange da vorne werden die
registriert müssen corona test auch
machen genau es ist ja mittlerweile hier
jetzt schon 19 uhr man sieht die kinder
sind eben auch noch unterwegs
wir haben auch heute auf der straße
gesehen die menschen werden eben
wirklich von der polizei eingesammelt
werden gezwungen ihren takes place wenn
man so möchte teilweise eben in einem
waldstück teilweise auf der straße
teilweise im alten abgebrannten lager zu
verlassen und dann hier hin zu gehen
also die polizei greift hier tatsächlich
sehr hart durch gehören auch gerade
wieder hinter mir wir werden immer
wieder gezwungen hier hinter die
absperrung zu gehen weil keiner möchte
dass man sich den flüchtlingen und dem
lager hier dem camp hier nähert also auf
jeden fall man sagt glaube ich momentan
das 5000 bis 6000 das sagt die
offizielle stelle flüchtlinge hier
untergekommen sind mittlerweile trotzdem
sind einige auch noch auf den straßen
unterwegs kempten dort war für sie klar
ist dass sie hier überhaupt nicht sein
möchten wir haben auch heute beobachten
können dass einige menschen aus somalia
zum beispiel da wurde eben auch deren
bildes camps sozusagen wurde aufgelöst
von der polizei und die haben sich
wirklich haben sich noch versteckt weil
für die diese zuständig hier einfach
untragbar sind und keiner hier sein
möchte also lieber auf der straße als in
diesem camp wir sind bild und wir
liefern dir deine news auf youtube zum
nächsten video kommst du hier
und vergiss bitte nicht unseren kanal zu
abonnieren